[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour ce
débat consacré aux élections municipales
dont le second tour aura lieu le 28 juin
des échanges des idées des controverses
sur France 3 chaque soir à 18h on est
ravi de vous faire partager cette
campagne premier débat ce soir sur la
ville de Montceau-les-Mines alors avec
nous sur ce plateau pendant 40 minutes
Marie-Claude Jarreau bonsoir bonsoir
alors vous êtes la mère sortante vous
avez pris la Villa gauche en 2014 et
vous avez votre liste au premier tour
votre liste de droite est arrivé en tête
avec 40% des suffrages Laurent selves
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous votre
liste de gauche à terminer en deuxième
position premier tour vous avez fusionné
avec une autre liste de gauche celle
d'Eric como bonsoir à vous l'Union
Noirot merci d'être avec nous alors vous
vous conduisez la liste de deux boules à
France vous avez recueilli 40 14 % des
suffrages au premier tour et en 2014
vous étiez tête de liste pour le Front
national alors on peut pas commencer
cette émission parler de ces élections
sans parler de ce qui s'est passé depuis
deux mois et demi le coronavirus qui a
tout bouleversé tout changé un entre
deux tours inédit 15 semaines entre le
1er et le second tour qu'est-ce qui
s'est produit je me tourne vers vous
Marie-Claude Jaro quel était votre
quotidien vous de maire pendant cette
période un quotidien compliqué à
quotidien exigeant un quotidien en
direction des montcelliets des démons
Célia
j'avais fait voter mon budget avant le
confinement ce qui a été beaucoup plus
pratique en termes de prise de décision
donc c'était le premier point que je
souhaitais aborder il a fallu organiser
très vite dès le 16 mars la continuité
du service public c'est-à-dire faire en
sorte que les monsilienne et les
monseliens puissent avoir un
interlocuteur à la mairie nous avons
donc mis en place un numéro unique
d'appel il a fallu aussi s'occuper des
plus fragiles dans le cadre du Centre
Communal d'Action Sociale leur mettre en
place les permanences téléphoniques
mettre en place les appels de chaque
jour
excusez moi de chaque semaine avec une
liste que nous avons utilisé du Plan
Canicule mais pas que donc veillez sur
les plus les plus faibles il a fallu
aussi
s'organiser pour que ces personnes les
plus faibles puissent rester connecter
avec leur famille c'est ce que nous
avons fait dans le cadre Montceau ville
connecté donc organiser les tablettes
organiser les rencontres tout ça a été
très exigeant en terme on va y revenir
peut-être dans le détail de ce que vous
avez fait et puis si je peux me
permettre il a fallu aussi
organiser les écoles puisque dès le
deuxième jour je crois nous avons pu
recevoir les enfants des soignants des
personnels soignants des forces de
l'ordre et puis les autres enfants qui
étaient prioritaires à la fois dans les
crèches et dans les écoles donc tout ça
m'a occupé mais c'est bien normal je le
devais bien au mont cellienne et
Monseigneur et surtout restez en contact
avec eux Laurent Selvez vous avez pensé
au covid ou aux élections vous
on a pensé d'abord au covid puisque
comme tous les Français c'est la
première préoccupation qui qui était
notre quotidien avec un arrêt brutal
d'activité sociale qui est quand même
été un gros souci et puis très vite on a
pensé d'abord à mon association puisque
je préside d'une association d'aide à la
personne donc il a fallu là aussi mener
un gros travail d'organisation de
continuité de nos services on travaille
dans ces normes bien sûr ça a été là
aussi une nouvelle étape dans la vie des
enseignants et des élèves une étape
riche mais qui a été assez prenante et
puis et puis la politique bien sûr nous
sommes en campagne avec mon groupe
depuis deux ans maintenant où nous
réfléchissons donc nous avons continué à
travailler notre projet à réfléchir aux
conséquences de cette crise
cette situation là elle avantage le
maire sortant
on s'est pas posé la question de toute
façon la situation était là il fallait
s'y adapter bien entendu ça nous a
permis à la fois encore une fois de
retravailler le projet et puis de de
préparer vous l'avez évoqué tout à
l'heure l'alliance entre nous deux
listes donc c'était tout aussi intense
très studieux et important pour nous
donc c'est un mélange à la fois de
politique de vie quotidienne de citoyens
dans une situation particulière de
président de l'association et d'élus
également puisque je siège à la
communauté urbaine donc là aussi
l'activité n'a pas manqué
vous cette période comment on fait pour
exister médiatiquement quand on est
adversaire du maire sortant alors déjà
moi je voudrais avoir une pensée ben
pour toutes les victimes de ce terrible
de ce terrible virus
je voudrais dire également merci à
toutes les personnes qui ont été
mobilisées pendant ce confinement et
après que ce soit les personnels
soignants mais également toutes les
autres forces vives que ce soit les
caissières les femmes de ménage bref
tout le monde donc déjà merci à merci à
toutes ces personnes pendant cette
période
nous ne sommes pas restés à rien faire
avec l'équipe d'ensemble le meilleur
pour mon saut on a travaillé j'ai réussi
à obtenir en tant que conseiller
régional de la région
Bourgogne-Franche-Comté après échange
avec la présidente de région des aides
pour nos étudiants soignants
aide-soignants infirmiers et quand même
de 300 euros par semaine donc c'est pas
négligeable au lieu de 50 € pour un pour
un étudiant de 3e année d'école
d'infirmière j'ai proposé à Madame
Jarreau diverses mesures en faveur de
l'économie locale de nos commerçants nos
artisans des exonérations de droits
terrasses de droit de place etc qui ont
d'ailleurs reçu écho donc je la remercie
cette période également moi je suis dans
le secteur privé je suis j'ai été
confronté en plein dans la crise en
raison de mon activité professionnelle
donc j'ai dû aussi gérer au niveau de
mon activité tout cela donc
nous avons été acteurs en ayant en tant
qu'élu l'obtention d'aide régionale
d'admunicipale et puis en tant que
salarié du secteur privé en tant que
professionnel j'ai aidé ensemble de mes
clients le seul acteur visible c'était
le maire est-ce que c'est la favorisé
d'après vous je ne sais pas je ne pense
pas les les résultats nous le diront
après moi je n'irai pas critiquer
l'action de du maire sortant et
d'ailleurs de Quimper parce que la
situation était inédite personne n'avait
vécu ça jusqu'à présent donc venir
critiquer ou dire que ça favoriser je
rentrerai pas dans ce débat là qui pour
moi n'a pas lieu d'être le job a été
fait il y a peut-être certaines choses
qui auraient pu être faites
plus vite et d'une meilleure façon mais
de faire de la critique bête et méchante
c'est pas mon dada Laurent Selvet est-ce
qu'il y avait encore une fille citoyenne
pendant ce confinement on la vie
citoyenne a été difficile d'abord parce
que ça a été un choc pour tout le monde
un arrêt brutal effectivement derrière
des contraintes nouvelles pour beaucoup
d'entre nous et moi aussi je le
souligner tout ce qui ont assuré leurs
activités dans des conditions difficiles
avec beaucoup de volonté pendant cette
crise donc la vie sociale c'est
organisée autrement bien sûr les réseaux
sociaux jouer là aussi de nouveaux rôles
nous ont permis de garder des contacts
avec nos proches nos familles et puis
nos électeurs on a on a beaucoup joué
sur ce cadre là pour maintenir un lien
politique et encore une fois continuer
de travailler ce que nous avons fait
pendant cette crise vous avez investi
numérique aussi Marie-Claude Jaro dans
cette période là j'ai surtout été
préoccupé par le fait de garder le
contrôle avec et la relation avec toutes
les monsilien et tous les monsiliens et
évidemment que le numérique ça n'a pas
suffi c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
avons organisé le téléphone dont je vous
parlais tout à l'heure et puis nous
avons aussi puisque j'ai pu moi sortir
nous avons aussi
apporté des paniers apporter les courses
organiser tout ça dès les premiers jours
du confinement c'était pour nous très
important avec mon équipe avec les
agents de la ville qui se sont mobilisés
très vite d'être à l'écoute des plus
démuttes des plus démunis nous avons
aussi par exemple
c'est tout bête mais nous avons aussi
fourni les attestations dérogatoires de
sortie c'était quelque chose qui qui
était fondamental pour la population qui
venait lors de sa promenade autorisée à
pas plus d'un kilomètre chercher ses
autorisations dérogatoires il a fallu
organiser des choses très basiques mais
très importantes pour la population
marie-claujaro de ce qu'elle a fait en
tant que mère est-ce qu'il y a des
critiques à faire sur
son travail pendant ce confinement
moi je regrette le manque de coopération
entre nous la crise imposée une
situation particulière qui aurait mérité
effectivement un travail commun nous
avons souhaité le faire nous avons
plusieurs échanges en particulier au
départ sur l'organisation de la
fabrication des masques moi je regrette
que ce n'est pas pu aller au-delà encore
une fois
l'époque
nécessitait qu'on aille au-delà de nos
difficultés de nos différences
politiques ça n'a pas été le fait
aujourd'hui madame Jaro évoqué le budget
un certain nombre de décisions étaient
prises pendant cette crise sans que
aujourd'hui nous ayons pu en discuter
démocratiquement vérifier effectivement
le cadre budgétaire aujourd'hui qui est
une grosse inquiétude pour moi pour la
ville de Montceau avec un certain nombre
d'annonces encore ces derniers jours qui
sont hors du cadre du budget que nous
avons voté en début d'année donc je
regrette ce fait là
alors Laurent selves comme tous les élus
comme tous les élus de la ville de
Monceau a reçu un point d'étape un point
covid vous avez reçu d'ailleurs le
dernier point covid juste hier ou
aujourd'hui par rapport au plan de
reprise de l'activité j'ai évidemment
fourni le budget consacré au vide
d'ailleurs nous venons d'apprendre que
nous allons pouvoir mettre ça en budget
annexe ce qui est très important c'est
un budget pour la ville de Monceau
d'environ 150 000 euros par rapport à
des aides par rapport à des exonérations
dont vous m'avez parlé et pour lesquels
je vous ai téléphoné je vous ai instruit
je vous ai
donné l'information donc il me semble
j'en suis même sûr que j'ai parfaitement
fait mon travail de communication en
tant que mère en direction de tous les
élus il y a eu simplement
un jour un petit quoi que vous n'aviez
pas la pièce jointe
et je m'en suis excusée auprès de vous
messieurs il y en ao est-ce que vous
regrettez vous qu'on a organisé ce
premier tour est-ce que c'est quelque
chose qui vous a tous poursuivi alors
oui moi j'étais favorable à cette à
cette annulation en tout cas du premier
tour et des résultats parce qu'avec une
abstention qui est plus de 65 % à
Montceau-les-Mines sur ce premier tour
personne n'a de légitimité personne même
moi je le reconnais
le gouvernement aurait dû annuler quand
on la veille on annonce qu'on ferme les
cafés les bars les restaurants tenir une
élection dans ces circonstances là et se
rendre quasiment responsable en tant que
tête de liste en tout cas moi c'est
c'est le c'est ce que c'est le feedback
que je peux avoir on a mis des vignes en
danger on a mis les villes de colistiers
et toute la population malin votée donc
le gouvernement aurait dû repousser
cette élection pour rebondir sur les
propos précédents les relations avec
Madame madame Jarro pendant cette
période du confinement en tout cas dans
les courriers que j'ai pu lui adresser
j'ai toujours une réponse on a échangé à
plusieurs reprises par téléphone c'est
peut-être faire preuve d'intelligence
aussi et de bienveillance et pas pendant
six ans avoir été quelqu'un d'agressif
dans les séances du conseil municipal je
pense que d'ailleurs toutes les
personnes qui ont assisté les élus
également à en démontrer que j'étais
toujours dans la notion de travail
d'intérêt général et
donc donc non cette période a été gérée
le seul quoi qu'il y a pu avoir c'est
quand j'ai adressé à Madame le Maire un
courrier concernant le risque pour les
réouverture de nos écoles maternelles et
primaires où j'ai pas eu la réponse je
n'ai jamais reçu de courrier de mail et
après avoir interpellé madame le Maire
j'ai reçu copie de cette réponse donc
non voilà je pense qu'il y a eu du
travail de fait et en tout cas on est
vraiment avec mon équipe et d'ailleurs
j'avais proposé dès le début du
confinement à Madame Jaro de mettre
l'ensemble de mes de mes colistiers à
disposition de la ville pour aider dans
n'importe quel secteur
concernant les colissiers je m'en suis
expliqué avec vous évidemment que ce
sont les élus et bien sûr les directeurs
de pôles et les agents de la ville qui
pouvaient se déplacer qui ont été
sollicités les policiers à cette époque
là n'ont pas été sollicités
ce premier tour ou pas non je pense que
c'est une erreur de maintenir le premier
tour de l'élection municipale
le gouvernement aurait dû avoir la
sagesse de l'annuler effectivement nous
avons pris des risques nous avons fait
prendre des risques pour un résultat qui
qui aujourd'hui n'a pas toutes sa
légitimité effectivement il pourra
arriver à une période où on se retrouve
pendant 15 semaines d'interruption entre
le 1er et le deuxième tour il aurait été
plus sage de l'annuler effectivement
alors on a parlé un petit peu de cette
période inédite je vous propose
maintenant de parler de ce qui va aider
les téléspectateurs à faire la
différence entre vous de parler un petit
peu du fond et de votre programme il y
en noirau est-ce que c'est actualité
elle a bouleversé changer votre
diagnostic et votre programme sur la
ville
j'ai envie de dire que la situation que
nous venons de vivre et que nous
continuons à vivre au contraire nous
donne raison puisque depuis 6 ans on
conseille municipal je ne cesse de
défendre et de promouvoir le produire
local le consommer local le fait lutter
contre également contre les
délocalisations ou même des fermetures
d'entreprises et notamment d'arrêter de
vendre nos industries nos fleurons à des
groupes étrangers on a quelques exemples
sur le territoire que ce soit la SIAP ou
même anciennement ppm qui sont partis
dans les mains de groupes étrangers et
on perd les brevets on perd nos savoirs
et en situation de crise dans de la vue
on peut pas avoir de masques on peut pas
avoir de gel c'est été un véritable un
véritable champlit comme dirait le
général de Gaulle donc là il y a une
véritable ça nous donne véritablement
raison notre programme a également
évolué je pense notamment sur la
question de la santé où elle a pris un
poids d'autant plus important nous
sommes sur un territoire où la santé
était mise à mal pendant des années où
notre hôpital a été clairement
démembrer
assassiné on n'a jamais réussi à avoir
un véritable hôpital communautaire de
pointe pour des guerres d'ego et cette
crise sanitaire doit nous faire
comprendre que nous en tant qu'élu nous
devons être de véritables VRP auprès
notamment
des futurs soignants que ce soit dans
les facs de médecine pour faire souvenir
s'installer des généralistes sur le
territoire mais également des
spécialistes qu'on mène un véritable
bras de fer un véritable combat face à
la RS qui tue notre hôpital à Monceau et
bien d'autres sur la région et enfin ça
met en avant de nos propositions phares
en matière de santé que sont la mise en
place au niveau de la ville de contrat
de santé communale et dépendance
communale pour aider les monsolienne et
les monsoliens à justement pouvoir avoir
une santé de qualité et pouvoir
également faire face aux soins qui sont
plus en plus importants même question
est-ce que votre programme du premier
tour il est complètement caduc
aujourd'hui ce qu'il y a d'autres
priorités qui ont émergé non bien
entendu le programme reste toujours
d'ACT j'allais dire heureusement parce
qu'après deux ans de travail sur ce
programme là s'il était aujourd'hui hors
sujet ça nous poserait question il est
clair que la crise sanitaire sociale
économique que nous traversons
aujourd'hui nous impose à avoir une
réflexion supplémentaire à affiner nos
choix et surtout à accéder à accélérer
un certain nombre de réponses qu'est-ce
que vous allez changer qu'est-ce que
nous allons changer essayer d'aller plus
vite encore une fois depuis maintenant
plusieurs années je regrette une
activité de la majorité sur tente sur un
certain nombre de sujets ils ont été
évoqués ils seront peut-être évoqués par
Madame Jarreau le cinéma multiplex qui
n'avance pas ça fait 6 ans que on n'a
pas bougé sur ce sujet là un skatepark
qui est en travaux depuis 4 ans
tout un certain nombre de dossiers je
pense notamment au cœur de ville qui est
un dossier important et sur lequel nous
aurions dû aller plus vite pour être
aujourd'hui opérationnel face à cette
crise donc il va falloir aller plus vite
sur ces dossiers là encore une fois et
puis il y a un secteur sur là aussi on
souhaitait mettre en place un certain
nombre de choses je parle à la
solidarité elle est essentielle
aujourd'hui dans ce dans ce contexte
solidarité avec tous les monsseliens que
ce soit les plus fragiles les familles
les commerçants les industriels
évidemment donc on avait un travail
important qui qui consistait à proposer
un nouveau service public d'aide
administrative de d'aider l'ensemble des
personnes à faire ces démarches qui
aujourd'hui sont parfois complexes
difficiles un certain nombre de
personnes ont pas réussi à comprendre
peut-être répondre le cœur de ville le
cinéma ça va pas assez vite qu'est-ce
que vous
je vais répondre à votre question déjà
et après je répondrai à Monsieur selves
évidemment que nous allons intensifier
un certain nombre de d'éléments de notre
programme évidemment par changer le
programme ça n'aurait pas de sens
notamment sur le métier par rapport à la
collectivité de d'agent de sécurité
sanitaire la sécurité
maintenant aussi la sécurité sanitaire
et ça c'est un travail que j'ai commencé
de mener avec les agents de la
collectivité alors quand j'entends que
Monsieur selves dit que l'opération
coeur de ville n'a pas commencé alors
comment aurions-nous été éligibles pour
construire dans le cas d'un appel à
manifestation d'intérêt des des
appartements des appartements sur la
friche Loison si l'opération coeur de
ville n'avait pas commencé si nous
n'avions pas été éligibles alors par
rapport au commerçants qu'est-ce que
nous avons fait en plus suite à cette
terrible crise et bien nous avons comme
beaucoup de mer d'ailleurs exonéré de
droit de place et de droits de terrasse
tous les commerçants mis en place mis en
place une plateforme made in Musso made
in Musso de clic and collect c'est à
dire qui valorise l'achat pour les
commerçants
plateforme elle est assez classique ce
qui est beaucoup moins classique c'est
qui elle est
organisée spécifiquement pour tous les
commerçants dans tous les quartiers
parce que l'opération coeur de ville qui
est une réussite pour mon seau et bien
elle concerne tous les quartiers et non
pas que le centre-ville
le cœur de ville à Montceau-les-Mines et
encore du travail dire que rien n'est
fait c'est mentir donc oui il y a encore
du boulot oui il ne faut pas penser non
plus qu'au cœur de ville qu'au
centre-ville parce que mon saut c'est
également en pléthore de quartier moi je
vais prendre un exemple simple vous
allez dans le quartier du Bois rouleau
ou même dans certains dont certaines
zones du bois du Vern il y a plus de
commerce il y a plus de il y a plus de
bar où les gens pouvaient se retrouver
ce qui crée du lien social il y a plus
de supérette etc donc il ne faut pas
raisonner que sur le cœur de ville on a
déjà donné des milliers des millions
dans le centre-ville il faut également
penser à nos quartiers parce que dans
les quartiers ce qui nous permettra de
sortir de cette crise et j'espère que
cette crise également redonnera
conscience aux gens qu'il faut acheter
et consommer local il faut que nous élus
on soit de véritable force de
proposition pour aider à l'installation
de nouveaux commerces dans nos villes et
inciter la chose
est-ce que le centre ville de Monceau il
a de l'avenir est-ce qu'il peut survivre
à cette crise sanitaire aujourd'hui dans
notre centre-ville nous avons des
commerçants qui ont envie de se battre
envie de défendre leur comète de
conserver une attractivité
on a la chance sur Montceau-les-Mines
d'avoir un centre ville et des zones
commerciales qui sont très proches donc
il va falloir recréer du lien des
liaisons douces entre ces différentes
zones pour effectivement se battre
ensemble parce qu'aujourd'hui face aux
commerces Internet les petits commerces
de centre-ville les commerces de
quartier effectivement sont importants
les grandes surfaces même à même combat
celui effectivement que les monsoliens
avec une crise qui s'amorce avec une
crise qui s'annonce et qui va aggraver
la situation il faut effectivement que
l'ensemble des monsoliens des habitants
du bassinier est plus largement est
envie d'aller sur le centre-ville
d'aller sur les zones commerciales et
encore une fois un monssolien il descend
en ville que ce soit sur les zones
commerciales ou sur son centre-ville ou
même dans ces quartiers donc c'est ce
combat-là qu'il faut mener et quand je
dis que de Villeneuve n'avance pas je
constate moi qu'il a fallu attendre le
mois d'avril de cette année pour
recenser l'ensemble des commerçants de
la ville je trouve que après deux ans de
projet cœur de ville c'est quand même
une démarche qui aurait dû être faite et
menée depuis bien longtemps nous avons
pris du retard l'objectif après le 28
juin et si l'on gagne c'est d'aller
beaucoup plus vite de rassembler les
gens de mettre les commerçants autour
d'une table pour avancer sur ces projets
sur des projets concrets
vous êtes pas d'accord bien sûr que non
le projet cœur de ville a démarré
lorsque vous nous avons été éligibles à
coeur de ville simplement ce que je
voudrais dire c'est que pour que les
personnes viennent à mon seau en
centre-ville consommer et dans les
quartiers je vous rappelle que la
gratuité des parkings je l'ai mis en
place je l'ai mise en place et puis je
voudrais dire à Monsieur selvesque en
2014 il soutenait une liste il était
d'ailleurs numéro 3 je crois sur cette
liste ou le centre-ville le projet était
de déplacer le centre-ville du côté de
l'embarcadère heureusement heureusement
qu'on en est pas là parce que nous
n'aurions plus à cette époque en ce
moment où nous parlons un centre-ville
et là la consommation communale le
patriotisme communal que nous défendons
aurait bien du mal aurait bien du mal à
exister alors l'autre thème abordé dans
ses municipales c'est la sécurité les
violences urbaines on sait qu'à
Montceau-les-Mines il y a eu des soucis
en 2018 à vous avez mis en place un
couvre-feu pour les mineurs Laurent
Selvais je me tourne vers vous quel est
le vote diagnostic sur ce point précis
là aussi les choses n'ont pas avancé
pendant ce mandat je le regrette et j'ai
l'occasion de le regretter très souvent
les premières caméras de
vidéosurveillance ont été installés en
2013 ces temps plus tard nous ne sommes
toujours pas opérationnels sur ce
dispositif donc on a pris un mandat de
retard donc il va falloir le rattraper
il va falloir prendre enfin conscience
de ces difficultés de sécurité qui sont
multiples de la ville le retard pris sur
les dossiers oui c'est vraiment la
faiblesse de la ville aujourd'hui on est
sur l'ensemble des sujets que nous
pourrons évoquer sur soi ce soir sur un
retard conséquent pendant ces 6 ans
encore une fois on a pris un mandat de
retard il va falloir maintenant
rattraper tout ce retard perdu y compris
sur la sécurité réorganiser le travail
avec la police nationale parce
qu'aujourd'hui le CISPD ne fonctionne
plus donc c'est la première tâche
redonner des missions claires et précise
à notre police municipale traiter les
les problématiques d'incivilité on en
c'est un vrai sujet sur mon saut que ce
soit la vitesse que ce soit les dépôts
d'ordures en dehors des déserts de dépôt
tout ça on constate ces difficultés
depuis six ans maintenant et je n'ai vu
aucune action concrète de la part de la
municipalité de ça
alors
2013 une caméra
2020 45 caméras
centre de supervision centre de
supervision lorsque nous sommes
sollicités par la police nationale bien
sûr nous donnons les images
CSPD il fonctionne nous avions encore un
groupement local de traitement
d'adélinquance la semaine dernière tout
fonctionne alors vous dites vous dites
des choses complètement inexactes 2013
une caméra
2020 45 caméras dont 5 mobiles
pour faire plus il est en noirau je
pense que ni monsieur selves ni madame
Jarreau ne peuvent donner de leçons en
matière de sécurité notamment monsieur
selves où il était quand même pendant 19
ans aux responsabilités où mon sceau a
attendu à devenir une pâle copie de
certaines banlieues du 9-3 il faut dire
il y a un trafic de stupéfiant qui
pourrit la vie dans les quartiers qui
pourrit la vie des années de gens on a
des gros problèmes de cambriolage on a
eu de grosses vagues d'incendie sur sur
différents sur différents quartiers donc
je pense que pour avoir une ville plus
sûre et aussi plus propre au quotidien
parce que la sécurité c'est également
une question de propreté il faut déjà
pardon exiger de la part de l'État parce
que c'est la compétence régalienne de
l'État davantage de moyens pour notre
police nationale on a un commissariat
dans un état vétuste des policiers
nationaux qui ont des véhicules dans un
état vétuste du matériel dans un état
vétuste donc la faute le gouvernement
mais de mes deux concurrents ont soutenu
et pour lesquels ils ont été au
responsabilités donc exigeons de la part
de l'État davantage de moyens déployons
de manière encore plus progressive et
dans tous les quartiers la vidéo
surveillance puisque après tout quand on
a rien à se reprocher on peut être filmé
en tout cas moi ça me gêne pas de
lettres d'autres villes telles que l'on
de l'ont démontré il faut également
avoir une police municipale plus formée
en recrutant notamment d'anciens
militaires d'anciens gendarmes d'anciens
policiers et il faut aussi mener une
véritable chasse sur la sur les dépôts
d'ordures sauvage donc si les monseulés
font confiance à la liste que je mène
nous nous pratiquerons la politique du
retour à leurvoyeur dès que l'auteur de
tout incivilité en jetant ses déchets
sera identifiés nous prendrons tous ces
déchets et nous les ramènerons chez lui
comme ça ce sera filmé la presse sera
informée pour prendre conscience
également qu'on ne fait pas n'importe
quoi c'est une preuve totale d'irrespect
et ce sera également en dernier point de
lancer des campagnes bien avec les
citoyens pour leur apprendre les gestes
de bon sens du arrêter tout jeté des
campagnes de sensibilisation de
nettoyage dans les parcs de la ville et
dans les quartiers alors on a parlé un
petit peu de vos programmes on va je
voudrais juste je voudrais juste vous
allez en retard un dernier mot très vite
que police nationale et police
municipale travaille ensemble et la
police municipale travaille toutes les
nuits quand à ce qui
concerne les dépôts d'ordures sauvage la
politique de retour à l'envoyeur je la
pratique depuis longtemps mais c'est
très compliqué c'est très compliqué
preuve à l'appui place beaubernard
notamment c'est très compliqué
d'identifier quelquefois l'envoyeur d'où
un déploiement de vidéosurveillance dans
tous les quartiers qui permettra
que les choses existent travail et
fonctionnent
je vous propose de parler de vos
stratégies
d'habitude tout se passe en 15 jours
entre le premier et le deuxième tour les
alliances les fusions les retraits l'un
des enjeux de ce deuxième tour du 28
juin ce sera la participation est-ce que
vous pensez leur en s'élever ce qu'il y
aura plus d'électeurs on sent pas les
gens passionnés pour l'instant on sent
pas forcément les gens passionnés il y a
eu plusieurs annonces contradictoires il
faut quand même rappeler qu'on nous
étions partis au départ sur un 21 juin
puis sur l'idée d'un scrutin plutôt à
l'automne et puis pour un retour à
nouveau 28 juin donc effectivement il y
a déjà une démarche pédagogique à faire
pour pour redire à nos concitoyens que
le que le vote aura bien lieu le 28 juin
que c'est important et qu'il faut aller
voter et cette démarche là est
importante donc nous nous allons la
faire ensuite
record à Montceau-les-Mines au premier
tour 65%, comment vous comptez
convaincre les électeurs marie-claujaro
et bien en tant que mère je une prise en
charge de l'organisation des bureaux de
vote évidemment que nous allons
communiquer sur l'organisation sanitaire
la sécurité sanitaire dans les bureaux
de vote c'est un premier point c'est
très important de communiquer de
rassurer c'est vrai que lors du premier
tour les personnes ont été déjà sidérées
par l'annonce du Premier ministre qui
consistait à fermer les restaurants puis
venez voter quand même le lendemain
c'était complètement aberrant donc là et
bien nous allons communiquer sur
l'organisation sanitaire des bureaux de
vote j'ai déjà commencé de le faire il y
en ao est-ce que vous pensez qu'il y a
une partie de la population qui va avoir
peur concrètement d'aller voter d'aller
aux urnes clairement oui je militais en
faveur du report de ce deuxième tour à
la rentrée septembre ou octobre les gens
actuellement ne sont pas du tout dans
l'élection on peut pas mener de
véritables campagnes on peut pas faire
de réunions publiques on peut pas faire
de porte à porte donc il faut
impérativement qu'on réussisse à faire
comprendre aux gens que le risque sera
quand même maîtrisé les services la
ville feront font le job et le font très
bien
la liste en tout cas que je mène et je
pense celle qui a le plus pati de cette
abstention record comme vous l'avez dit
à Monceau
à nous aussi également de revoir
peut-être notre façon de travailler de
penser pour redonner confiance également
au mensuels dans notre action au
quotidien alors on va parler des
alliances je le disais au démarrage de
cette émission Laurent selves vous avez
fusionné avec la liste d'Éric como vous
avez reconstitué l'ancienne municipalité
de Didier matthus
je voudrais rappeler à Monsieur Noiron
que ça ne fait pas 19 ans je suis en
fonction des luges c'est bien plus
récent que ça non il ne s'agit pas de
reconstituer l'ancienne équipe de Didier
matthus même si on compare les mandats
de Didier et puis celui de Madame
Jarreau je dirais qu'il n'y a pas photo
et Clément solien avait une autre vision
de leur ville et il y a encore 6 ans en
arrière donc en photo ça veut dire quoi
il y a pas photo c'est que nous avons
nous avions une ville dynamique avec une
politique culturelle reconnue un
dynamisme économique une ville qui qui
se développait et aujourd'hui ce n'est
plus le cas malheureusement l'activité
d'attractivité de notre ville a
complètement péricliné pendant ces 6
dernières années et ça fait partie d'un
énorme challenge que nous avons à
relever à partir du 28 juin cette année
en jeu principal de cette campagne
vous vous sentez en danger vous alors je
voudrais dire que je suis très étonnée
par cette alliance puisque le 22 janvier
2020 monsieur selves décrit
déclarait dans la presse j'ai beau
chercher sur les photos la présence
d'erikomo au moment des problèmes de
l'hôpital je ne l'ai pas trouvé puisque
vous avez fait échouer
ne me coupez pas la parole s'il vous
plaît monsieur selves puisque vous avez
fait échoué le projet qui consistait à
la création d'une transformation dans le
cadre de l'insertion d'une
transformation de de conserverie de
fruits et légumes par Monsieur Bonan qui
était venu nous voir en 2016 vous avez
fait échouer ce projet alors qu'il était
soutenu par la Communauté alors qu'il
était soutenu par Blanzy donc vous
prenez des policiers pour lesquels vous
avez été peu sympathique c'est c'est eux
qui nous l'ont dit donc ce sont des
drôles d'alliance et puis alors ce qui
m'a étonné ce matin c'est de voir vos
affiches c'est de voir vos affiches
votre affiche monsieur selves et vous
êtes tout seul vous avez même pas vos
colistiers en photo vous êtes tout seul
monsieur drôle d'alliance Laurent Selvet
non je trouve que Madame Jarreau a une
analyse de la situation très
particulière la vérité c'est la vérité
c'est votre vérité je ne sais pas vous
allez chercher vos informations mais sur
l'hôpital madame Jarreau j'aurais bien
plus de reproches à vous faire car
monsieur como vous avez été complètement
absent de ce dossier pendant ces six
années vous avez sacrifié la chirurgie à
l'hôpital de Monceau vous êtes resté
muette pendant ces semaines de covid
alors que l'hôpital traversait une
situation plus que difficile que son
personnel souffrait que les patients
étaient en souffrance les familles sans
information et aujourd'hui encore vous
restez muettes sur un dossier alors que
l'ARS alors que le GHT revient avec
force pour supprimer un nombre un
certain nombre de services sur notre
hôpital donc je crois que nous n'avons
pas de cette alliance elle va être
efficace oui bien sûr mais nous ça vous
donne 120 voies d'avance si on
additionne au premier tour vos deux
scores une très bonne chance de
l'emporter au deuxième tour nous sommes
devant si nous additionnons nos deux
listes et encore une fois cette alliance
elle est le fruit de notre travail y
compris avant le premier tour nous nous
sommes rencontrés à de nombreuses
reprises avec
Eric nous avions discuté sur le projet
et encore une fois la différence entre
nos deux listes était finalement si
faible que c'est alliance s'est fait
naturellement alors certes le temps nous
a aidé effectivement si nous avions eu
plus qu'une semaine entre les deux tours
ça aurait été plus compliqué mais moi
j'ai souhaité qu'on parle le projet
qu'on parle de Monceau qu'on parle des
monsoliens des monsolienne et pas de nos
intérêts personnels et je crois que
l'ensemble de la liste aujourd'hui a
envie d'aider cette ville envie de
s'investir pour elle et je crois que
c'est le principal et je crois que les
monsoliens sont en train de le
reconnaître à propos d'alliance il y en
Aro est-ce que vous avez été tenté de
vous rapprocher de discuter avec
Marie-claude Jaro non après moi pour
revenir d'un ordre beaucoup plus global
on connaît le bilan de de Madame le
Maire sortant on connaît le bilan de
celui qui a la tête d'une liste alliant
la gauche extrême avec les bobos écolos
pro macronistes et pour laquelle on sait
de quoi elle est capable c'est notamment
le pire on ne l'a subi pendant on l'a
subi pendant 19 ans c'est de
marionnettes d'un côté Éric como de
l'autre côté Didier Matus qui chapeaute
tout ça avec Laurent selves qui est
actuellement
euh le chef de fil alors moi je veux
justement éviter un morceau et au mont
ce lien de reproduire le même fléau que
nous avons vécu pendant 19 ans je ne
souhaite pas que les monseliens aient à
choisir entre l'un ou l'autre alors
c'est pour ça qu'on propose un autre un
autre programme des autres idées et j'ai
envie de dire soit on a page soit on
continue mais au bout d'un moment les
perdants seront Clément soliens et on
s'arrête là il reste une minute Marie
Claudia où vous avez un peu de retard
dans votre temps est-ce que vous avez
pensé vous à discuter avec debout la
France alors moi je risque debout la
France est plus respectable que le Front
national c'est l'étiquette de 2014
vous avez dit dans votre introduction en
me présentant je mène une liste qui n'a
pas de couleur politique c'est une liste
de mon cellienne et de monselia
compétent engagé pour leur commune donc
nous avions un programme nous l'avons
écrit ensemble nous l'avons écrit avec
les monselies et les monselia donc et
bien nous n'avons pas songé des
alliances des alliances comme sont en
train de faire monsieur como et Monsieur
selves sont des alliances
presque de la carpe et du lapin de la
carpe et du lapin qui n'ont pas de sens
et j'ai donné deux exemples très précis
merci on arrive à la fin de cette
émission donc c'est l'heure des
conclusions on va commencer avec vous
l'union de moiro vous avez une minute
pour conclure alors je suis le candidat
du privé j'ai l'expérience de
l'entreprise face à une crise économique
sanitaire écologique et social que nous
sommes en train de vivre et qui va
s'amplifier dans les mois à venir et les
années à venir
il faut à la tête de la municipalité de
Monceau quelqu'un qui a l'expérience du
terrain quelqu'un qui va avoir la poigne
pour aller
soutenir nos entreprises soutenir
l'ensemble de nos acteurs
socio-économiques et c'est le combat que
mène la liste ensemble le meilleur pour
mon saut nous souhaitons une politique
juste et de bon sens avec mon équipe
donc j'invite l'ensemble des mentionnés
des monsoliens allez voter pour nous
c'est faire le choix du renouveau c'est
faire le choix de l'alternance mais une
alternance nouvelle et surtout on évite
de reprendre les mêmes et encore de
continuer dans la même direction qui est
c'est celle qui était dessinée c'est ces
30 dernières années merci Lilian Noirot
c'est à VOUS Marie claudiaro de conclure
vous avez une minute en 2014 nous avons
avec mon équipe récupérer notre ville
dans un état lamentable monsieur selves
était premier adjoint école insalubre
restaurant scolaire plus aux normes
désertification médicale avancée
centre-ville dégradé berges du Plessis
abandonné aucun projet pour les jeunes
au fil des années nous avons découvert
d'autres choses encore un éclairage
public très vétuste des espaces sportifs
vieillissants nous avons mis en place
créer rénover reconstruit notre ville
une maison de santé deux espaces
jeunesse des logements individuels pour
notre résidence des peupliers quatre
restaurants scolaires une politique
d'insertion en direction des jeunes un
projet social vrai projet social otu un
pôle santé départemental une politique
naturel un skatepark l'action cœur de
ville nous souhaitons poursuivre
construire un nouvel éclairage public
rénover ça en gros pour suivre l'été du
lac poursuivre la mise en place des
caméras la liste est mémo sauts est
composée d'hommes et de femmes
compétents et engagés qui tout
simplement est mon saut merci
Marie-Claude le dernier mot c'est à VOUS
Laurence Alves
nous aimons tous nos saut et le 28 juin
sera déterminant pour l'avenir de notre
ville il faut mettre fin à la politique
que je dénonçais tout à l'heure mené
depuis six ans qui a conduit peu à peu
notre ville vers le déclassement c'est
relevés le défi de la démographie
retrouver un entretien régulier pour
notre ville nos quartiers un cadre de
vie agréable une sécurité qui soit enfin
prise en compte et traité redonner à mon
sauce on attractivité commerciale son
attractivité économique et surtout et en
tout cas ce sera l'urgence remettre nos
finances municipales dans le droit
chemin c'est ce que je vous propose avec
l'équipe que je conduis maintenant
depuis plusieurs mois une équipe
effectivement compétente avec un soutien
retrouvé là aussi c'est quelque chose
d'important de la part de la communauté
urbaine de son président des maires du
bassin minier
et puis une volonté qui nous anime pour
mon saut qui peut gagner le 28 juin si
vous votez pour Monceau 2020 énergie
citoyenne merci à tous les trois d'être
venu échanger et des batteries ici sur
ce plateau de France 3 Bourgogne sur ce
second tour des élections municipales à
Montceau-les-Mines secondaire des
élections qui sera donc prévu le 28 juin
on se retrouve chaque soir n'oubliez pas
à 18h pour un débat dans votre ville en
Bourgogne merci d'avoir été avec nous et
passer une très belle soirée sur France
3 merci merci
[Musique]